[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Ivan ramen on Manhattan's Lower
East Side where I'm joined by Just Blaze
he's a legendary hip-hop producer he's
made beef for everyone from jay-z and
Beyonce to Drake and Kanye West but what
you might not know is that he's one of
the music industry's biggest most
devoted ramen junkies would that be a
fair characterization Keef and I'm
actually opening my own ramen restaurant
in Jersey City oh if I'm does this thing
I'm asking you to hire me by mouth I'm
gonna do and what I like about you is
whether it's solo or its horror movies
generally it doesn't have just hobbies
Just Blaze gets really nerdy about all
the things that he would my thing is the
objections to this before this movie if
you're gonna do it doing way otherwise
my mom and I remember being should we be
in a ramen house I switch went on and
that was it doesn't take long to prepare
doesn't take long to eat you know but
what it's done right it's just as good
as any four-course meal that you have at
a super fancy stop
so the ramen scene has exploded in
cities like New York and Chicago over
the last ten years and today we're going
to get a crash course who gets laid as
well as one of the most celebrated ramen
masters in NYC in this Ivan Orkin but
first another awkward segue to the
kitchen to figure out what the hell
we're eating for lunch
[Music]
when I started this whole process I
didn't know anything I was already a
pretty seasoned chef I worked for many
years and yet the whole Robin making
process seemed daunting to me because I
would watch them make bowls while I was
eating in Tokyo and be like what are
they putting in there what are they
doing why do they do that so Robin was
running with one of the things that I
did it didn't understand just by looking
at it so this this challenge of taking
something I knew nothing about and
owning it and doing it really well it's
really exciting she Robin is my
revelation you get an empty bowl you
fill it with todday and fat and Little
Caesar our noodles are very thin and
they cook very quickly in 40 seconds we
serve a double soup so it's a whole
chicken soup and a dashi which is soup
based on smoked shaped fish and kombu
which is Japanese so silly we cook pork
belly that's been lightly seasoned and
cured and then we roast it very slowly
and put a slice of that on top with a
sort of a six minute and 30 second egg
it's really nice when the yolk kind of
breaks into the broth it adds some
viscosity and a lot of flavor and
there's some scallions on top what is
authentic I mean I'm one of the most
authentic ramen shops in America as I'm
concerned if you want to look it that
way I'm not saying that to be a jerk
interesting this whole idea of
authenticity
I mean ramen is one of the most sort of
inauthentic things and I could take you
to Tokyo and I could take you to shops
that each shopper booths so drastically
different from the other one but they're
popular there's no standard in ramen
making there is no rulebook if it tastes
good and people like the way you serve
it you succeed and if they don't you
fail all right so we're here at the
table I've been here just lays this here
and of course they got a full table of
food and I'm happy that I have a couple
ramen nerds here because there seem to
be so many rules when it comes up how
you keep drama right Ivan can you give
me the plan of attack and you give me
ramen I don't know once what are the two
rules only two
rule number one a la pop the best and
then I see people taking a now and
habitable Robin community and then you
want to flip it you get all the broth
all the flavor kind of ripping up into
your mouth and it and a great way to
have it about you know step out of
balance
yeah the balance of the flavors when you
try to eat a piece meal like I'll have a
little broth a little piece of chicken
you kind of gave the purpose right mix
it's totally true take a little bit less
than you're thinking so you plug your
practice your Square and then you want
to slurp it up like you drink really hot
coffee in the morning you know you need
that first step and it's burning -
together exactly okay so you're just
right there you know
nailed it nailed it you know my first
try when you slurp you get a rhythm you
get your renge and your variables in
your specifics involve eating some
cashew and you're eating an egg and and
all the sudden you look up in the bowl
champagne look good since I have the
ramen guys at the table I'm gonna bounce
some common ramen myths and common ramen
things that people say and I'm going to
just get your snap sake I'm what do you
think is true whether you think it's not
true and just sort of your position on
these things alright instant ramen it's
just for college kids they don't eat
that stuff in Japan and those are better
than a lot of the moves that you see in
the restaurants I'll eat it yeah and in
Japan they do they do want to the
average price in about three dollars you
it comes with a boil backpacks and
different seasoning packs and you peel
it back before the Waterloo this cook
when you add in all the fat and it
tastes like rock
ramen it should be cheap blast like the
bane of my goddamn existence I'll tell
you what cases three days to make a bowl
of ramen
then people like lows it's $15 just
ridiculous well you're not my shop is
just a restaurant we happen to make one
I can take into Italian restaurants
where a plate of the spaghetti from a
box with
very tasty fresh tomatoes on top 27:28
and everybody thinks that's okay like
the guys are artists when I come out
switched up some Tomatoes want some pop
are there any parallels and balance and
a ramen bowl more balanced in a song
I think anybody's ever asked me that ah
the average person is not losing to a
reckoner be like well you know what that
the vocal performance was going to be
sipping over to the right about you know
two degrees and if maybe they just
change the compression ratio under a
master fader every person's ago that
means but we understand that all those
elements that go into making a great
level the same way for the divers odor
so we don't expect you to make a great
bowl problem this will actually no not
jobs to shape that I had never a moment
with my wife where we both ate somewhere
great and then like later on in the day
we'd look at each other with a smile on
our face at the same moment and was
totally clear that we were both smiling
about that meal we had right it was such
a moment and I was just like you know
yeah you know that that's what foods
great that's when you have a meal with
somebody and later on you're both just
still in it well the best part of ramen
is when you get to the broth so I think
that we should close with a little pale
a little little bold off cheers slimes
wrong list so I'll just I'll just
pretend I'm party to party or killer and
over here
Cheers
you
[Music]
I appreciate I owe